well those archipelago books run by Jill
schoolmen who again they're devoted
entirely to literature in translation
which really makes him unique there is
open letter press run by Chad post who's
very dynamic and articulate much more
articulate than I am advocate for
translation he had been at dalkey
archive and then started this new
imprint at University of Rochester press
and they in fact are going to be
publishing was the borders next
anthology which is a celebration of the
20th anniversary of the fall of the
Berlin Wall coming out this November and
Judith gurvich who was a psychologist a
psychoanalyst who is I believe
hungarian-born started a publisher which
has done a lot of translation which is
the name of which is just going to
demand will come back and of course
farrar straus Knopf echo Metropolitan
still play an important role but they
are under pressure from the larger
corporations that that own them always
and so there's a limit to what they can
do
well number of the authors that we have
published have then gone on to get book
contracts because they got noticed
through through our efforts it also
certainly makes it easier in practical
terms to be in touch with authors in
foreign countries and and with
translators and measures who are living
abroad it makes it possible to feature
the original language text alongside the
English translation which is fug for
students or foreign languages and and
because it is accessible everywhere
fifty percent of our readers are
actually not in the United States so it
enables somebody somebody in Iran to
read a piece from Indonesia even if they
don't read Indonesia